so um
this talk is going to be a little bit uh
unconventional so uh
i'm as you can see from the plan so
i'm not going i'm almost not going to
have
any results and the only results i'll
talk about are not my own
and some of them are not even correct
and
and yes and uh
yeah so um i think uh yeah so
if you like this kind of talk then
like it if not then hopefully the apple
talks
will make up for it and
so this is the plan and i'm going to
skip to the
actual results about the sum of squares
in relation to
problems in machine learning unique
games conjecture and quantum information
theory and be happy to talk about them
if people
are interested during the breaks okay so
i'll start with
a prologue talking about solving
equations with radicals so
this was kind of all the rage for the
first few thousand years of doing
mathematics and you know the babylonians
came up with this
solution for quadratic equations that we
learn in
depending on the country between i guess
indians probably learn it at birth and
americans landed in college
but
and then for a long time
this is all people knew and it was
actually like
this was a huge part of doing
mathematics and and solving even
particular examples and
and in fact people would hold like these
kind of duels where they would
pose each other's equations and then
at some point in a story that has a lot
of intrigue and some
solemn oaths that were later broken and
then the solution for cubic equations
and degree 4 equations was discovered
and
revealed and published and
but then people still wanted to solve a
higher degree equations there was this
story of
one woman who challenged this
crazy 45 degree equations to all the
mathematicians in the world and
uh t is the king henry the fourth that
none of these mathematicians can solve
it and then vietnam solved it
realized this was something
trigonometric so even very very smart
people
worked very hard on very even particular
cases so
euler tried very hard to solve to get a
formula for degree 5 and couldn't but
solve some special cases lagrange i
think try to solve
x to the eleven equals one and couldn't
but then van der monde
managed to solve it and a gauss
er solved the equation excellent 70
equals one using only square roots
and this also amounts to constructing a
17 gone with a straight region compass
and um this was his first big result he
was very very proud of this result
this is actually the the result that
made him
decide to become a mathematician in the
world
we still don't know how much the the
science of linguistics
was set back because that was his other
option
and uh and he wanted they actually
wanted the
the 17 gone uh etched on his
tombstone but the mason refused he said
it he looked
too much like a circle no one would be
able to know the difference
you can decide if the mason or gauss was
right
and so uh so so
you know everyone kind of and then you
know a lot of other people worked on
these problems like leibniz walked until
and and the card and um you know so all
these
geniuses worked very hard on these uh
kind of
special cases etc and and we but we
didn't really understand what's going on
until this sequence of work of uffini
abel and galwa
where they realized that some equations
actually don't have a solution in
radicals
and in particular there is no general
formula
for solving degree five equations like
there is for degree two three
and and four and uh but they they
understood more than that they
completely characterized the equations
that are solvable
in equations that are not solvable uh we
using group coe this is actually the
birth of group theory and the notion of
solvable groups
in particular now we understand
completely why you can solve x to the 17
with square roots because 16 is a
because 17 is a prime of the form two to
the two to the n plus one
and we understand exactly why uh uh
x to the eleven can solve with square
and fifths because
these are the factors of ten and uh so
we completely understand now
these equations etc and as a consequence
we don't do this anymore we
mathematicians don't solve
uh equations in radicals anymore now
it's boring and you know they think that
gauss was so proud you know this genius
was so proud of
and and once ed wanted etched on his
tombstone is now something that you do
with like few lines of mathematica and
it's not because of the huge power of
computers
it's it's just a very mechanical routine
calculation now
so okay so this
what does it have anything to do with
what we are doing so now let's look at
the
kind of what's happening right now in
theoretical computer science
and a typical tcs paper and actually not
necessarily typical for
this kind of workshop but let's say
people not doing logon
so general you know theoretical computer
scientists
they come up with some interesting
problems some obstruction of some
problem that people actually want to
solve
in reality and then and they'll do one
of two things
you know either they solve this
algorithm for example you know we
for them focus on show that you know you
can solve maximum flow or
million other problems that are in p or
they show that it cannot be done
under uh you know right now under
computational assumptions
and as long as these
we are not able to get rid of these
assumptions right now the lower
bound researchers so you know prove that
they say
so sometimes you find an efficient
algorithm sometimes you find and how
this reduction sometimes you show that
in one parameter regime
the problem is easy and it never is hard
and
in both of these cases these things
require a lot of creativity
so so every one every one of those
problems
is a paper and on its own and requires
the creativity to come up with the
efficient algorithm or to show that it
cannot
be solved so the question i'm asking is
can we make algorithms boring like we
did for you know
solving equations with radicals yes my
students think i've solved that problem
can we make it boring even for us
it's a challenge to make it boring for
boring people you know
so so so so this is uh
so so this is a challenge this might be
too much but let's let's make it a
little bit
less can we can we reduce creativity in
algorithm design can we make it
somewhat more systematic and and this is
not just
you know to save work and uh to
you know to to to just save work but
because really what happened also in the
case of equations
it's not just that you made things
routine you also
understood them better the reason that
they're boring is also because you now
understood the general principle
and you have a much better understanding
so can we actually get
a similar understanding like we
characterize the solvable equations
get the characterizations of the easy
problems
problems that can be solved in
be with um problem right he wanted to
you know automate the comments i'm
trying to give an analogy with a
successful program
yes so um
so can can we do that so this is the
question uh
i'm asking let's let's try try to
understand this question a little bit uh
or the version of this question that i'm
trying to ask
better so what does it mean to
characterize easy problems in some sense
characterizing the problems the the
solvable problems
is kind of a universal solving routine
you know you want a single simple
algorithm that will solve all the
problems
that can be solved that would be
basically an understanding a
characterization
and of of the easy problems
exactly so this is trivially true
there is a simple algorithm very simple
algorithm that solves all the problems
that can be solved this is the algorithm
that
enumerates during machines and
what it only solves from you can only
really do that for nba intersectional
and key problems
i think np you can do it into the login
time or whatever
put a clock on it but in any case this
is
also i mean i didn't exactly specify but
in success that my goal is also
trivially false because a simple
algorithm should be an algorithm where
we can analyze its running time
and if you could analyze the running
time of a
universal algorithm like that you would
settle p versus np in particular we
don't know i mean we have this algorithm
but it's i don't consider it simple
because we can't analyze it spanning
time
so so in some sense depending how you
phrase this goal
it's even really trivially true
trivially false so try to find a way
that it's
neither one of those things so let me
revise the goal
i want a single simple algorithm that i
can analyze
and i'm not going to prove that it's
optimal i'm going to conjecture that
it's optimal
and probably not for all possible
problems because then again we'll go
into two realities
but rather in some interesting domain of
problems so this is
somehow the revised goal and
the rest of this talk i'm going to talk
a little bit about uh parts of this
kind of research agenda and in
particular the next slide i'll tell
say something about the interesting
domain but i don't have a good
definition
of the interesting domain more than some
vague
uh vague notions of what it might be
like
the first part of the of the rest of the
document will be about what is this
single single algorithm that
one candidate for this algorithm and i
don't have
partially because i also don't have the
sense of what is the domain also don't
have any good
nice clean conjecture so i think even
finding the right conjectures is still
an open problem here which i very much
hope that some people will pick up
and the second thing is that once you
have the such understanding even if it's
only conjectured you can get some
by-products one of them is maybe new
algorithms which
i'm skipping today mostly but another
thing is somehow
if you really characterize what
efficient computation can do
you somehow can get better understanding
of it and you can get some kind of a
theory of
what computationally bounded observers
know and i'll talk a little bit about
that
so so this is basically
the plan any question at this point
okay so here is the the general domain
er
it's some undefined subset of computer
tool optimization
now i don't think any everyone agrees
with computatorial computation
optimization here and i'm not attempting
a definition but here's some kind of
properties that are commonly associated
with optimization so usually
optimization you're thinking of you know
you're trying to minimize or maximize
some objective function
subject to some constraints and some
examples that people
normally include in this group are you
know satisfiability
max cut max coloring travelling
salesperson
matching etc and some things that don't
seem like combinatorial optimizations
are like
integer factoring or like problems like
avi talked about er
er computing determinant etc
in some properties of the optimization
is that because we are trying to
optimize some objective then there is a
natural notion of
uh approximation that uh
it's interesting to ask about trying to
satisfy
get some of the objective and there is
also a natural notion of noise
typically it makes sense to talk about
someone perturbing the instance and
asking for
some robust kind of algorithms
there is a relatively little algebraic
structure in optimization you see less
of these magical cancellations that help
you say compute the determinant or
things like that
and the world of optimization also seems
a little bit cleaner in the sense that
uh
some complexity assertions that we don't
think are too
uh in general seem to hold like in this
world in the sense that
for example in optimization uh it's
often the case that if a problem is in
np and in the current p then it's also
in p
this is the notion of edmonds called it
good characterization when a problem you
have like
you can certify that there is a solution
and they have a dual certificate there
is no solution
usually there is also an algorithm also
quantum
algorithms and the wave notwithstanding
don't seem to do a lot
you know don't seem to give exponential
speed up in this domain
and often uh with these combinatorial
problems you also don't have this very
strange
uh algorithms like you know the number
field sieve for integer factoring that
one in time like two to the n to the one
third you
the problem are often either very easy
or very hard even
yes why do you think integer factoring
isn't an example of combinatorial
optimization
every definition i would give for a
combinatorial optimization would include
it
okay so this is so this is where we
differ
one i i think of computer optimization
as satisfying these properties
and and none of them holds for uh
integer
uh factoring so uh so so if you want you
can
you can think of this is the kind of
this is some unspecified
class of problems that we behave like
this
multiplication whether you want to use
matrix multiplication
that's also uh i'm right now not
distinguishing between say
like let's say different polynomials etc
so definitely like fast matrix
multiplication i kind of
it's too fine grained to consider here
but uh one yes do you think the
hamiltonian circuit problem is part of
combinatorial optimization
that's a good question uh which i was
hoping to kind of sweep over under the
drug even matching etc
so so so okay i'm not trying to define
computer optimization in some sense i
would want to look at the subset of
combinatorial optimization but generally
speaking the probably the
the the kind of intuitions that i'm
going to talk about are
more appropriate for soft constraints
than for hard constraints
so you can think of constraints
satisfaction problems
or maybe some generalization of it and
possibly also i mean learning a circuit
it's not something or traveling
salesperson it's not something thought
enough about but in some sense
i'm typically thinking of kind of soft
constraints or problems that are robust
to noise
where so if you wanted to solve
i mean so you might want to talk more
about longest path
and than you know exactly hamiltonian
like trying to you know maximize the
path rather than to say
exactly it's hamiltonian and but in one
one
one again characterization of this class
that i'm not exactly defining is that
the same
ideas and themes keep recurring so if
you look at the you know some
great textbooks on optimization you'll
see uh
some algorithmic themes that keep
repeating again and again where
for integer factoring for example you uh
for other problems you might have like
very ad-hoc
ideas that are very very specific to
this problem and and one of those
themes that keeps recurring is a
convexity and we'll this is what we'll
talk and the hope is that we somehow
want to make this formal and say
this theme for some class essentially
characterizes what can be solved
so so so like i said i'm
going to talk about convexity so i'm
guessing that in this audience you kind
of
know what it is so basically you know if
i wanted to minimize
a function if i wanted to minimize this
function
it would be very easy i will drop a
marble and it will fall right
to the global minimum if i drop the
marble here it will probably get stuck
in one of those local minimums
and you know generally this is why these
kind of problems minimizing a convex
function is much easier than
minimizing non-convex functions and
so so convexity is something that is
used again and again and again you see
linear programming semi-definite
programming you see
uh general uh kind of convex forming
again and again in
algorithmic optimization and um and the
way it's usually used
is the following the problems sometimes
the problem is convex but often the
problem is not convex it's not even
continuous most of the problems we talk
about when we talk about optimization
at least we talk about maybe some other
optimizers actually talk about
continuous problems but
minimizing some function over the
boolean cube which is a discrete set
so typically the general tcs paper will
look like
you you start with the interesting
problem that you have
you find a way to embed it in some
complex problem you
make a relaxation and then you solve the
convex problem
and you know for example uh
they said plus minus one uh you know the
boolean cube
we can embed it in the solid cube and
then there was this brilliant work of
gomez and williamson
and that instead of embedding it in the
boolean cube embedded the
eating the you know the set of unit
vectors and got something and
whose set of gram matrices is convex and
got
some better results and my problem with
the problem the work of governments and
williamson exactly is that it was
brilliant
so the problem is that this this this
step uses
the c word which is a dirty word in this
talk it uses creativity
so we want to get rid of creativity and
go to design
yes
we will force it to kill its own yes so
uh so so and this this is where this
kind of sum of squares
uh algorithm comes in so it's at least
one method to try
to get basically a universal embedding
of any optimization or like at least
some optimization problems it's
some technical sensors it cannot be
applied to any optimization but it's
really more natural
to some of them and not for others uh
into
a an end to the d-dimensional convex set
and this is kind of an algorithmic
version so it was done by
different people independently including
and this is kind of an algorithmic
version of problems that
arrives arose from hilbert's 17th
problem of
certifying that a polynomial is not
negative by expressing it as a sum of
squares
and and and the this is
a kind of a universal embedding where
you can make the convex set bigger and
bigger by increasing this number of d
as you make it bigger the it's less
efficient it runs in time
and to the d but uh but it also becomes
better in some sense
better quality and you typically in the
problems that we care about when d
becomes n then it's exponential time but
also
solves the problem perfectly and it
turns out to encapsulate many natural
algorithms including
linear programming semi-definite
programming and a lot of combinatorial
algorithms
and there is a very nice recent result
of prasad with
liam store that showed that it's
optimal among natural class of
semi-definite programs for solving
constraints satisfaction problems so
so this is the algorithm we are kind of
going to look at as a
candidate for somehow an optimal
algorithm
and um and
now so so this is the algorithm
and the algorithmic candidate and now
i'm going to
uh so any question about this
this last result that you mentioned it
seems to be along the lines of what
what you want right it's some kind of
yes
well i mean i hope that it i mean this
this last result is about some
natural class that you can prove low
bounds for which unconditionally
uh maybe we could hope that it's true
for any polynomial time algorithm
and then we can't really prove this
unconditionally but we could still hope
that it's true
uh okay so by now i've done you know my
dubious historical
analogy i philosophized about algorithms
and i waved my hands about
convexity and the sum of squares
algorithm so
i can now do the sudden shift to
bayesianism versus frequentism
and then talk about the non-results on
the planted clique
so more things that good things are good
to be coming
yeah you just believe the topic does the
sum of squares algorithm solve growth
matching
uh no about for the stp not solving it
but
what about some squares in there i think
i i am i'm i don't think it does
no there are low bands yes i don't think
it does
yes so again there are these issues
we've kind of
had constraints that uh it does
it does not seem super well suited for
okay so now
uh what vision is versus frequentist
so uh so this is somehow uh
one of the longest i think running feuds
in uh
science uh which i've heard compared to
the shias versus the sunnis
and you know it's um
yes
so so this is kind of a long running
feud uh
between uh frequentist invasions of on
the
like the these two camps of uh
statisticians or probabilist
and um one way to kind of say
to the to describe the difference
between these two camps
is to look at this statement so as far
as i know people have computed pi
to uh i don't know like the billion for
of billions digits something like 10 to
the 13 and
and they still haven't computed the 10
to the 20th digit of pi
so you could ask you could say well
i mean what's the probability that this
10 to the seventh digit of pi
is seven and so suppose you make this
statement the
the probability that it tends to the ten
to the twentieth digits of pi is seven
is ten percent then you know a
frequentist like uh poisson would say
this is
absolutely nonsense there is no problem
the
the 10th did we might have not computed
it but the 10 to the 20th digit of pari
is either seven or it's not seven
there's probability zero one there is no
sense in which this probability can be
ten percent
well uh you know a beijing would say uh
so are you willing to take a bet with me
i will bet you you know
if you're willing to take eleven to one
odds uh i will bet you that uh you know
this digit is seven so uh so this is
basically the the difference
uh bayesians kind of view probabilities
as talking about
uh beliefs about knowledge and
uh well frequentists uh think of
probability as being chosen from some
sample space and if there is no sample
space there is no probability
yes you should
take into your beijing account that
someone is willing to make a bet that it
is
but so if
you should condition on someone being
willing to take the back yes
that that might mean that they have
computed it yes that's
that's good that's that that is that's
one of the issues why i
think i see a frequent is hiding you
that's one of the objections that
usually
is about the subjectivity of
probabilities and uh
yeah so basically as i think a
theoretical computer scientist uh
i was not even aware of this debate
until not too long ago because we are
naturally frequentist i mean
even when we pretend to be bayesians we
use bayes rule we
we do so with we really are talking
about
uh there is a sample space
and for us probability you know is
always
some measure on the sample space we
think in worst case terms which kind of
corresponds to the frequency spots and
so unnatural tendencies to be a
frequentist but
but i want to actually go and talk about
the bayesian version
of probability here and it seems like
it might also seem like this all debate
is kind of like these kind of
things like interpretations of quantum
mechanics where it doesn't really matter
and all empirical predictions will be
the same but it actually is not the case
and definitely not a case where you take
computational analogs
and so so let's look at cinco for more
computational version and pi was also a
computational version but this is maybe
more precise
so suppose you're given this monster is
a random graph
and and i tell you you know there is a
click here the maximum click has size k
and asking what's the probability you
know this
what's the probability that vertex 17 is
in the click
so you know information theoretically
this probability is either zero or one
you know this is the the it's completely
determined what the click is given the
graph
and um and and then the u versus vector
17
is in the uh you know is in the set s
and if
and if it's not i just downloaded this
graph from the internet so i don't know
the answer but if you do know and
find out please let me know yes there's
no vertex 17.
i don't know it's uh this is the
numeration
so and so but you know if you're a
computationally bounded observer you
you might say that my probability of
this is more or less you know k over and
as far as i know vertex 17 especially
since i didn't tell you which one is 17
it is a more or less equivalent to all
others
so you know as far as i know it's
basically k over and
the probability that 17 is in this
clique so now
i'm trying to make this kind of more
precise this so this is kind of the
bayesian
kind of world view and i'm trying to uh
to make this a more precise so
so so we have this graph with maximum
click and how do how does beijing think
uh subversion will say
uh we model our knowledge by
defining this posterior distribution so
we have this uh distribution over sets
which we identify with
uh z1 to the n and
um so it's a distribution you know it
sums to one
it's a non-negative number something to
one and it needs to be consistent with
our observations so
consistent with our observation i would
say uh you know it's supposed to be
distribution over clicks
so it better not have a positive
expectation for some
non-edge if i and j are non-edge then
the expectation of x x j should be
should be zero so in that kind of
captures
uh that's a general invasion way to
capture our
our knowledge and the problem with this
is that uh
what yes yes this is supposedly a
distribution on clicks
the problem on with this is that you
know this is going to be
a you know
this really captures what the
information theory i mean this has no
computation into in it and
you know this will really be only a
distribution on clicks
so we kind of need to relax this to talk
about computational versions so i wanted
to talk about computational invasion
uncertainty and
the it might not be clear how to relax
it and the
way i'm going to propose to relax it is
to change the world distribution to what
i'll call the degree d pseudo
distribution
so what is the degree this is the
distribution it's basically
uh the same uh exact thing
except i relax uh one condition and this
is the
kind of you know this kind of strict
insistence
this uh petty insistence on
probabilities being non-negative
so the way i kind of view it i mean
there is a
an israeli saying that um
you know it's okay to piss in the pool
but don't do it from the dive board
so no i see it's okay to have negative
probabilities
but don't be blatant about it so you
know you can you can have negative
probabilities but don't be blatant about
it in the sense that giving
that have an expectation
you know a square low degree polynomial
that has negative expectation
so pseudo distribution is one that hides
its negative probabilities and
and you know doesn't shout it from the
rooftops
and
so instead of asking that for every x
it's not negative
we ask that the low degree square
polynomials
will have a non-negative expectation
okay so this is at least a well-defined
notion
and note that the the set of this
of this kind of distributions the set of
vectors is a convex set
if i take a convex combination of mu and
u prime satisfy this condition the the
convex combination also satisfies it
and um you know it really is defined by
only end to the d equations and uh some
pseudo psd constraints so
so so it's really easy it might look
like two to the n-dimensional but it
really is in in some
into the d-dimensional and you can solve
it in time uh
optimize in time and to the d and really
this is another way
this is the the sum of squares algorithm
so the sum of squares algorithm for the
click problem
given the graph g it will give you the
maximum over all the degree d so the
distributions
of the expectation of the size of the
set
and in the color of this definition the
two things first of all
if we look at degree n so when we look
at degree n the delta function
the function that for every x uh just
sets whether x is uh you know uh
just is one uh the the function
for every x the delta delta x function
that on input y
it outputs one if x equals y and zero
otherwise
is a degree n polynomial and therefore
you can actually get this constraint but
when you go
all the way to degree n you actually get
this constraint
so therefore uh when you go all the way
to degree n
then you get the click number of the
graph the set of pseudo distribution is
the same
of actual distribution generally
when uh when you have lower degree then
the set of pseudo distribution is bigger
than the set of actual distributions
because
you have fewer conditions and therefore
this number could be bigger the sum of
squares and a number
is an upper bound on the click number
which could be bigger
if you look at degree 2 then it turns
out to be exactly the same as the lowest
stata function
so so the sum of squares when you
arrange d between t
and n is somewhere between the tether
function and the click number
so if you look at maximum of all
distributions
if you look at the maximum of all
possible distributions on actual clicks
of this thing this would be the click
number
okay yes right and when d
becomes n or 2n let's not ignore let's
ignore these issues uh
then then this is the same as
distribution so the distribution and
distributions are the same because this
condition implies this condition
when these smaller then you're
maximizing over a richer set
and therefore this maximum could be
bigger and generally
this maximum will be i'm not sure if i'm
defining the set of function with
respect to the graph
it's complement like let's look at the
set of function when it is an upper
bound on the
on the click number and this number will
be between the theta function and the
click number
so now i kind of
this is really defined with respect to
the sum of squares but uh
i as far as i know there is no technical
work that have done it but
in some sense this sense this notion of
pseudo-distribution i think
can be defined more generally um
it might make more sense to with any
proof system
so in some sense you can think of you
have a sound but incomplete proof system
you might need some properties of this
proof system like
relating in some sense to complexity but
i don't know what they are and i
know this is i've never written anything
like this down and i don't know if
anyone else has
so but this is a somewhat of a general
recipe so you have like a sound but
incomplete proof system
pi and with sum of squares you can think
of it as a sound but incomplete proof
system
then a pseudo distribution with respect
to pi that
is consistent with some set of
observation has the property
that if the observation tell you that a
function needs to be larger than some
number alpha then the expectation needs
to be larger than the alpha
so someone that is only restricted to
drawing inferences using this incomplete
system pi
cannot detect that this pseudo
distribution is is bad
and and and because pi is incomplete
this might be more general than an
actual distribution
and and in some sense this i think this
notion of pseudo-distribution is the
computational analog to vision
probabilities and generally the way i
think about it is that
you know uh frequentist versus bayesian
is like pseudo is if you take a
computational analog to frequent these
probabilities you get
the classical notion of
pseudo-randomness
uh and if you take a computational
analog to basis probabilities you get
this notion of pseudo-distribution
and where the classical notion of
pseudo-randomness with distinguishing et
cetera it corresponds to algorithms
where
here it kind of corresponds to proof
systems
so it's an observation so so
it's a set of so in our case like it's
it's supposed to be clicks right so you
have some constraints that
us supposedly so it's supposed to be
somewhere so the distribution over some
set
and and so this is somehow uh
i think i think i find it somewhat
interesting that
normally if you look at bayesian
probabilities and frequencies
probabilities they are actually like
somehow technically the same but if you
try to make computational analogues then
it seems
you're led to very different very
different notions because this is kind
of
this kind of corresponds to beliefs and
and
but anyway and
okay so now let me talk about uh the
planted click problem because i do want
to get a chance to annoy my friends
and so this is a problem that i think er
originates from former friends maybe
originated with dick
and the way i are going to i'm not the
way i'm going to define it is not
exactly the classical way of saying
you trying to distinguish between a
random graph and a random graph where we
added the click on top
and let's define it for this talk this
way
and uh you know lava status function
show gives for a random graph a
square root and value and it's always an
upper bound of the click number
and therefore it solves this problem
when uh
the lowest letter function solves this
problem when the implanted click is
larger than square root n
and not know there is no known point in
polynomial time algorithm that's better
than that
and this is really a very central
problem in average case complexity
we don't have too many problems that you
know we can serve and you know have been
reduced to various things and we really
want to understand the complexity of it
and there uh
there is a theorem by a faging crowd
camera that says that
the lowest driver plus hierarchy and you
don't have to know what it is
it basically it's some algorithm that
runs in time n to the d it gets
it can detect a click of size roughly
square root and divide by two to the d
and this is basically the best trade-off
we know this is the best uh
algorithm we know and the question is
can the sum of squares algorithm which
is a generalization of this
ls plus can you do better
this is a question that lots of people
were interested in
and therefore people were very excited
when
the two gentlemen sitting here announced
that in fact summer squares cannot do
better
and and cannot beat squad and for any
constant degree
so it means that uh the sum of squares
with the grip parameter two gives it's
always an upper bound on the click size
and in in the random graph it gives an
upper bound of squared and it means that
if you try to plant a click a click of
bigger size you will detect it because
you'll get different values in the
random graph and in the
planted case so that's why the sum of
squares algorithm
can detect uh a click when it's bigger
than square root n
and and and having a good claim that you
cannot do better
and and the way they they proved it they
defined the pseudo distribution
in fact they they looked at the same
pseudo distribution that was used by
fake and crowd gamma
uh for this ls plus and it's kind of the
distribution pseudo distribution
of maximal ignorance roughly speaking
basically
it's what i said uh before they said
well you know
look at every particular vertex the
probability that's in the click it's k
over n
look at the pair of vertices if they're
an edge then you know if they're not an
edge then obviously they're not in the
click but if they're an edge the
probability is roughly k squared over n
over n squared with some constant which
i'm ignoring
and uh and etc and and then they
uh you know they reduced showing that
this is a valid pseudo distribution to
a higher degree analog
to general common generalization of the
you know the chain of bound to matrix
valued and also to
iodine polynomials and each one of those
individual generalization was known in
in two and it seems like
this definitely should be true so and
so so so they basically it's
it really seemed like this is all
correct but then you know some annoying
guy
came in and showed that the
concentration bound is uh
is actually false but then you know you
could still think okay maybe the
concentrations in the you know
they should have the you know they have
used because
not exactly the right concentration
bound and you can fix it but then
another annoying guy
showed that in fact this
pseudo-distribution is uh
is not a valid sort of distribution
actually kelln and john cannot show that
there is a polynomial a quadratic
polynomial
that it's you know if you
use the distribution the expectation of
p square
p squared is negative i understand
wasn't it
just for s so ls doesn't require this
condition
so it's okay for s-plus but not for
someone right ls plus it's okay for
for it to have this property but for sum
of squares you cannot
uh yeah so um
yes so uh and and and and eventually
turns out that
things are not all bad like uh if you uh
if if you were willing to go with a
lower click then uh you know in ragu
navi actually and
with uh our new and then later some
other works that improve the
uh the exact number in the exponential
that
this this pseudo distribution this
maximal ignorance sudo distribution
does uh does it does uh
does work to show that sum of squares is
at least not super great
but it still leaves up in the question
of this scroll with n
so so now i mean i want to dwell
more about uh like what exactly
was the problem in uh make a video on
the reasoning
not because you know i'm just a person
like to dwell on other people's arrows
i mean only not just because of this
but also because i think it actually can
teach us something
so uh so yes
yes i think that some people's mistakes
are actually very
interesting so so i want to claim that
you know they didn't make just a
technical error they made a morale
you know einstein maxim einstein said or
he didn't exactly say that
maybe that you know student distribution
should be as simple as possible but not
simpler
and another way to say it is that
pseudo distributions should have the
maximum entropy
but they still need to respect the data
we need to respect the observations
and uh and and this maximal ignorance
to the distribution has lots of entropy
too much entropy doesn't respect the
observations
and and and the reason it violates
bayesian reasoning
so let's think about it okay so
uh think of the you know the expectation
you you you look at some vertex i like
we said
and you want to know what's the
probability of the ties in the click and
initially we said well the probability
is covering but let's think a little bit
more
if we're two bayesians let's think a bit
a little bit of what about what data we
have
and uh and how we should be interpreted
so one thing we definitely know about
this vertex is it's degree
and generally it's a random graph the
degree is going to be n over 2 but not
exactly right
it's going to be n over 2 plus minus
square root n
you might think okay no my plus minus
square root n is not a big deal
it shouldn't really change a lot the
probability but let's think about it so
so basically this is what it makes of
ignorance they say they said it's
essentially k
over n maybe one times like little or
up to the lower order terms uh so so
the maximal ignorance distribution said
basically this probability is k over n
but let's think about it so if let's be
bajan
so if i was in was not in the clique
then it's uh it's degree is just a
random
you know poisson viable you can think of
it as a gaussian with
n over two uh n over two expectation and
n over two by and so square root n
essentially standard deviation
uh but if it was in the click then it's
shifted you have k more neighbors
so it's basically roughly speaking it's
like n over two plus k
expectation and the same standard
deviation
so these two random variables are
shifted
but notice that if k is almost squared n
then this shift is almost a standard
deviation
so this is actually some significant
difference in these distributions
and therefore when you see that
when you see that a vertex had degree n
over 2 plus square root n
you should give it higher probability uh
than
like some significantly higher
probability say one point
zero zero one factor or more than the uh
if you see
a vertex at a degree and over two minus
square root n
and and and so more technically you
should really weigh
the expectation of x i by the
probability
uh under this versus the probability
under this which
you know it's proportional it's rewind
so constant factors don't matter it's
proportional to something like this
where
if you think of k as roughly square root
n and delta roughly square root n this
is
basically like one plus some small
constant
plus or minus small constant depending
on whether delta is negative or positive
and in fact if you do these bayesian
moments then
uh you know in this new work that some
of the there are some people here that
are co-authors on
uh you you actually do get square root n
for degree equals
uh for degree four and it's still uh
wide open on whether you get above that
so now uh let me and why did i find this
so interesting so
the reason i find this error so so
interesting because it really shows that
some of squares captured bayesian
reasoning
where ls plus couldn't
and in some sense also like this notion
of vision reasoning at least to me i
find it very interesting because in some
sense
a way to try to attempt to define what a
computationally bounded
uh observer knows and maybe it could be
useful
in some other setting even maybe even
you know computational economics or
other settings where you could try to
basically
have a theory of like what what is
knowledge for computationally bounded
observers
and it's also a somewhat
it turns out that this is kind of a way
to design both low bounds and algorithms
uh in in some of our works kind of try
to use this
pseudo distribution to design algorithms
now
a lot of people might say you know there
is absolutely no reason to assume that
you know sum of squares is the optimal
algorithm
uh and uh and i agree and
we still this is still in its infancy uh
and
and one of the reasons i'm trying to
make these bold claims is because i hope
that people will
you know give bold counter examples and
help you know
try to give people motivations to refute
them
but i think that um unless we see a very
good reason that this quest is
completely hopeless
uh we really should not kind of give up
on
this kind of dream of trying to find for
some class of problems
uh especially this kind of combinatorial
problems where it seems that the
ad hoc tweaks are less needed and more
they're more common algorithmic things
to try to find some kind of a more
general theory that tells us what is
hard and what is easy and how to capture
knowledge
uh it's somehow too attractive a dream
to kind of
give up so so even if sum of squares is
not the answer i hope something else
is
questions
yes this analogy with the solving
equations
are supposed to tell us the time scale
so in 2000
yeah that's a that's a good question
where are we in the in this request are
we like the babylonians or are we like
the italians with their duels
okay yes
exponential moments i don't think those
are quite the moments we use
this is the moments you will use you
don't know it yet but
in the final version of your paper this
is the ones you will use
yes
yes when i give this talk at connell
someone said well thank you for not
you know for relative being relatively
mild with the things you promised that i
will prove
so he was afraid i will i will i will
you know committing to proving even much
more things
so